hello my name is Jim Chapman this
gentleman here is Colin from Jeju hat
Center in New York and we're going to
learn as much as we can about how to
write now so let's begin with the top
hat the first modern hat tell me a bit
about it well the top hat was very
popular in 1802 England passed over to
the United States definitely as well you
see that with Winton's famous stovepipe
hat Elsie Lincoln's hat was very tall is
that kind of like a correlation between
how tall your hat is to kind of how cool
laughter what you are no not necessarily
top half at the time tended to be
extremely tall a good foot over the head
was not abnormal there were even top
hats that you could actually wear to the
Opera and when you took it off you could
flatten the top hat and simply put it in
your pocket and the end you snap it back
out and there's your top hat again I
love it so next up let's talk about the
bowler hat how did that come around the
bowler hat was originally designed as a
hat for gamekeepers who needed to be
able to ride in a state and not knock
their cop hats off there's interesting
how it's not just a fashion accessory
kind of evolved from the top hat to make
it more useful for they're actually
useful absolutely and a lot of the time
with hats function sort of perceives
fashion in this case though the bowler
became the most popular hat in the
entire world
uh-huh it was worn by everyone from
butchers to businessmen bankers people
think of the cowboy hat as the hat that
won the West in it but the bowler was by
far the most popular hat in the American
West
interesting next up the Stetson which is
of course the iconic cowboy hat how did
that happen
so John B Stetson went west looking for
gold I didn't really find anything he
did however find beavers to make a hat
out of and someone who had had
significantly more success than him in
the gold panning business Saudis hat
liked it and paid him a five dollar gold
piece so that must be quite a lot back
then it was definitely a lot and this
was a hat that he'd made out in the wild
so he decided he could probably do
better making hats than looking for gold
and went back to Philadelphia and began
doing that so I hate the name of the
Fedora actually came about from a play
about the princess that's correct
to play
was actually called Fedora character was
Fedora and the Hat she wore was a soft
hat with a with a wide brim so
originally the Fedora was in fact a
woman task just but it rapidly became
the most popular men's hat in the world
part of the reason for that is it's much
more customizable than the bowler ear
right it's soft and originally what you
would get when you went into a store for
a fedora is a hat that looked something
like this okay round top brim and that's
all you really had and then at the store
the salesperson would shape it for you
right so you could have him put just a
center dent with some creases in it you
could have him put more of a teardrop
shape in so it was flat there okay
basically whatever it was you were
looking for you could have your hat
shaped that way so that is the end of
this video thank you very much for
watching and of course they key to Colin
and JJ hat Center for lending us what
felt like millions of hats for the
history of hat video we filmed make sure
you check out other hat related content
on GQ and of course don't forget to
subscribe so GQ and myself so can you
just look at people's faces and go hmm I
know I haven't suit you I'm fairly good
at that at this point